mais là messieurs bonsoir le successeur
de paul si c'était lui il s'agit du
cardinal albino luciani c'est le
patriarche de venise
il a choisi son nom de pontife jean paul
1er
le pape a donc été élu au soir du
premier jour du conclave
mais cette élection n'a été confirmée
qu'après un bon quart d'heure démission
de film peut d'ailleurs je crois que
nous avons en direct à l'instant jean
claude d'arrigo et victor vraiment de
nos envoyés spéciaux à rome ita vraiment
je pense que cette élection au premier
jour du conclave est une véritable
surprise c'est une surprise
effectivement parce que bon même si on
pensait que ce conclave durerait
peut-être deux peut-être trois jours on
ne pensait pas en tout cas que le
successeur de poissy serait élu le jour
même il ya donc eu quatre votes quatre
tours de scrutin
et c'est le gardien luciani qui a été lu
et puis il ya eu aussi un une chose
assez étonnante aujourd'hui ce soir
c'est que à 18h30
il y avait évidemment des milliers de
personnes rassemblées place saint-pierre
et tout le monde
regardez la fumée qui allait sortir si
ça vous allait être une fumée blanche
qui allait annoncer l'élection du pape
ou bien une fumée noire qui allait
annoncer que les cardinaux ce n'est pas
dit d'accord alors ce qui s'est passé
c'est que à 18h30 lee a bien vu la fumée
mais personne n'a été capable de
préciser s'il s'agissait de fumée
blanche ou fumée noire c'était si vous
voulez qu'une fumée grise
alors quand même une heure plus tard il
ya eu une certaine effervescence les
gens assis et nous avons les images de
en même temps victor continuer oui alors
les images de sa vie c'est pas mal c'est
devenu clair parce qu'il ya quand même
une certaine tradition c'est que au bout
d'un certain temps après l'élection du
pape le camerlingue apparaît au balcon
central de la basilique saint-pierre et
il emploie la formule traditionnelle que
tout le monde attend que des milliers de
personnes attendaient cette formule
c'est avait mousse papam ce qui veut
dire nous avons un pape
et puis quelques instants plus tard ce
fut l'apparition du cardinal luciani qui
a donc pris le nom de jean paul 1er mai
alors il faudrait peut-être comme se
poser la question parce que le carnet de
szczesny n'est pas tellement connu je ne
pense pas qu'il ait fait une
une carrière une très grande carrière à
rome oui c'est la deuxième je crois
c'est la deuxième surprise la
personnalité du pape il n'était pas dans
les papas me lit on en a parlé un tout
petit peu dans les papabili au début
mais on ne prononce et plus son nom car
ces jours ci vous le saviez on vous l'a
dit assez souvent c'était le cardinal
badges ou et le cardinal bertoli qui
semblaient être les favoris mutuel le
cardinal ou seul alors le carnet luciani
a ceci de particulier par rapport à ses
prédécesseurs que c'est et j'allais dire
un pasteur et rien qu'un pasteur pie xii
jean xxiii paul vi avait et j'allais
dire des avait fait des carrières
diplomatique préalablement avec du
contact avec le monde alors que le
cardinal luciani lui a eu une carrière
d'une certaine façon classique
il a été ordonné prêtre relativement
gérable au d'arrigo jury navré de vous
interrompre mais nous sommes
actuellement sur la tranche d'eau de nos
confrères et ne pourront pas plutôt
content il mais je pense que nous allons
pouvoir vous rappeler en cours de
journal en attendant je vais demander à
notre chroniqueur religieux drastique de
de nous préciser la personnalité nouveau
pontife oui sa personnalité ce qui est
le plus important c'est que c'est un
pasteur et un pasteur encore plus d'une
certaine façon que jean xxiii c'est un
homme je crois très simple qui vient
d'une famille très simple il est âgé de
66 ans d'abord il je crois d'après la
dépêche je ne connaissais pas en toute
honnêteté il brise dépêche que je viens
de recevoir qu'il n' est donc le 17
octobre 1912 à fort no 10 canal et dans
le diocèse de belluno nord de la vénétie
oui son père était artisan verrier amour
1 auprès de venise et a dû émigrer
c'est en même temps donc un fils
d'émigrés à un moment donné de même sa
mère est une femme je crois très simple
qui faisait la plonge dans un hôpital de
venise et
nocentini je crois qu'il faut dire que
il me semble à première vue que les
cardinaux se sont mis s'il est d'accord
d'abord parce qu'il ya eu une
préparation ça pour moi je suis certain
qu'il y a eu une préparation pendant
pendant les jours derniers
d'autre part c'est un candidat un
candidat par exemple signifie en effet
sa désignation relativiser peut-être un
peu trop rapidement les cardinaux en
deux grandes familles les progressistes
et les conservateurs
quelle famille le cardinal la mouche à
nice rapprocher et bien pour moi il a
pris le nom de jean et de paul et je
crois en hommage à jean xxiii et apple 6
et j'aurais premièrement tendance
d'emblée tendance à penser qu'il est
plus proche de jean xxiii parce que
c'est avant tout un homme de terrain
et comme une vanne homme de terrain je
pense que par exemple il va s'intéresser
beaucoup d'affaires italienne et qu'il
est le candidat du kernel benelli pour
moi donc proche des aphasiques à vienne
donc il va être un pasteur d'abord pour
l'italie et il va à mon sens assez bien
laisser faire le synode c'est à dire les
évêques de tous les pays qui va très
bien comprendre que les évêques de tous
les pays des conférences épiscopales les
différentes nations doivent essayer de
résoudre les problèmes eux-mêmes
alors pour moi je crois que ça a été un
candidat d'union autour des questions
pastorales de toutes les questions de la
base à réaliser je vous cite le canal de
bologne jacques auréolé carreau en
parlant de l'avant car au mieux oui
c'est un sage et un salon du nouveau oui
et je crois que c'est un sage thème qui
est qui sera acceptée par tout un
ensemble qui va je pense laisser faire
des collaborateurs il n'a pas si vous
voulez la capacité de synthèse à
première vue de paul si ce qu'était un
homme d'une extrême intelligence mais
par le fait même il va tout en plus
laissé du champ où différents
collaborateurs et ça va être beaucoup
plus collégiale et le gouvernement de
l'église à mon sens comme un peu jean
xxiii l'avait fait en annonçant le
concile pas s'il avait demandé au fonds
l'aide des évêques du monde entier
alors il y à d'énormes problèmes et là
je pense qu'un pasteur
est un homme sage et un homme simple va
d'autant plus être accueillant à tous
les problèmes de la base la non
désignation des grands quand des grands
que des grands favoris comme le canal
badjo par exemple je te le dire que ce
jean paul premier sera un pape de
transition
est ce que c'est un sélection un tel un
compromis à votre avis pour moi ce n'est
pas un compromis
c'était une ouverture vers quelque chose
de deux simples de beaucoup plus proche
de la base et je crois que c'est un
désir exprimé par un certain nombre de
cardinaux que ce soit du tiers monde ou
que les cardinaux français
j'allais dire et à première vue un homme
comme moi
le cardinal marty ou est assez proche du
cardinal du ctia parce que c'était la
même façon de prendre les problèmes à la
base et quels sont les très grands
problèmes de l'église aujourd'hui c'est
l'ensemble des problèmes du tiers monde
c'est l'ensemble le problème de la femme
dans le monde l'immense continent
asiatique
enfin mont saint martin a plusieurs fois
parlé c'est un cirque raison parce que
il n'y a que très peu de catholiques en
asie tout le monde des jeunes qui
quittent la foi la foi chrétienne un peu
partout dans le monde et en europe tout
particulièrement
donc là tous ces problèmes là un pasteur
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui est la
sensibilité de la base est très
important oui mais ce n'était pas un peu
en contradiction avec le fait que nous
signale que c'est un grand théologien
on le sait le chien est un peu un
philosophe un homme qui est un peu à
l'écart des préoccupations concrètes
non quand on regarde comme le cardinal
de munich par exemple bon le cardinal
ratzinger donc est un grand théologien
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse dire que le
kenya luciani il a fait son doctorat en
théologie sur os ministre je ne souviens
bien c'était sa théologie à la gardienne
il a certainement été très bien formée
par les jésuites de la grégorienne
mais ce n'est pas un cran et le chien je
pense que savons-nous un piste donc
c'est un homme qui certainement va
tenter de de mieux faire comprendre le
concile plutôt que d'avancer encore
certainement que ça va être un homme
crie va dire le concile avant tout le
concile et rien que le concile il va
essayer de faire en sorte que le concile
soient mieux appliquées et ce en tant
qu' il faut faire la synthèse justement
jean xxiii et paul vi vient pour mieux
le connaître le nouveau pontife
je vais vous demander de regarder la
documentation que nous avons pu
rassembler sur lui et qui va vous être
diffusé à l'instant pour mieux connaître
le nouveau pape jean paul 1er
voici sa vie personne ne l'attendait ce
nouveau pape sy n'était pas parmi les
favoris les favoris vous allez tous les
voir les uns après les autres sur ces
images tournées par notre envoyé spécial
jean claude darrigues le nouveau pape
albino luciani les depuis 18h24 depuis
7h il est le nouveau pape de l'église
catholique
il a choisi de s'appeler jean paul 1er
un homme chargé de sens jean pour jean
xxiii paul pour paul 6 albino luciani
en choisissant d'être le premier jean
paul annonce qu'il sera tout à la fois
l'église du renouveau celle du concile
vatican 2 l église de l'ouverture et de
l'oecuménisme celle des voyages de
police le nouveau pape est né en 1912 il
a donc 66 ans un âge somme toute
raisonnable pour un souverain ponte
il devient prêtre en 1935 évêques en
1958 et patriarche de venise en décembre
69 pool6 fait de lui un cardinal au
titre de saint marc en mars 1973 jean
paul 1er
le pape est un fils d'ouvrier son père
était artisan verrier sa mère faisait la
plonge à l'asile saint-jean-de- paul de
venise après ses études doctorat en
théologie il devient le curé d'une
petite paroisse à fort no 10 canal
toute sa vie il a enseigné la théologie
et c'est un spécialiste de la catéchèse
il a écrit un livre catéchèse bribe par
bribe qui en est aujourd'hui à sa
septième édition
nous sommes un peu bouleversé évidemment
dans dans l'ordre de ce journal parce
que cette vous avez pu constater que
l'annoncent de l'élection de jean-paul
premier est arrivé très tard et je pense
que nos envoyés spéciaux vont pouvoir
nous rappeler au cours de ce journal ou
tout au moins pour la dernière édition
du journal deuxième titre de l'actualité
aujourd'hui un titre plus concret et
plus proche de dépenser des français les
retours de ce dernier week-end du mois
d'août
en fait pour tous ceux d'entre vous qui
attendent les membres de leur famille
sur la route on peut dire tout de suite
que la circulation routière tout en
étant chargé qui se chargent un peu plus
d'ailleurs à l'heure actuelle ne
présente pas de gros ralentissements les
spécialistes de cette circulation pense
et espère qu'il n'y aura pas de
difficultés majeures ce qui concerne la
rentrée de demain d'ailleurs vous le
voyez sur ces images prises
d'hélicoptère dans le courant de
l'après-midi les conséquences
les conséquences de la grève des
contrôleurs maintenant eh bien elle
semble cette fois ci plus limitée que
pour l'instant d'ailleurs que lors des
départs en vacances en gros on peut dire
que les compagnies aériennes ont annulé
quelques vols et que de leur côté les
organisateurs internationaux de voyages
ont essayé de limiter les dégâts en
mettant en place un système de
rapatriement par route
l'un des points chauds de ce
rapatriement c'est l'espagne de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
français doivent revenir en l'espace de
quelques tenues de le revoir une
correspondance de gérardmer rigaux
et faites les ponts un avion qui se
posent à gérone c'est un exploit qui
sera de plus en plus difficile à
réaliser à partir de ce soir
à l'heure où l'aéro station en terre le
programme apollo certains ici aurait
envie de crier
il a réussi il est passé seulement s'il
a réussi et s'il est passé il n'est pas
dit qu'il puisse s'en retourner les
quinze à vingt mille personnes qui
transiteront par gérone au cours de ce
week end
nombreux seront ceux qui devront dans
les meilleurs des cas attendre le feu
vert des contrôleurs français les autres
cet encart qu'ils rentreront les
français en particulier puisque dès
maintenant des autobus chargé de
touristes arrivent de france à gérone
nous avons décidé en accord avec les
compagnies aériennes de mettre en place
des cars au départ de villes de france
vers gérone
le seul aéroport qui nous permettent
d'acheminer les passagers vers les
valeurs nous pensons commencer à
recevoir les nous allons recevoir les
passagers à partir de ce soir et les
acheminer par un pont aérien que nous
avons mis en place depuis gérone sur pas
loin quand on vient de strasbourg gérone
ans quand ça représente combien de temps
nous avons il n'y a qu'un jour disant
que le cab strasbourg gérone ont mis
plus de douze heures
faut comprendre que les gens soient pas
à la bonne humeur en arrivant si ça
serait logique que nous essayons ici de
les accueillir d'une manière très
sympathique nous leur expliquant et
c'est très difficile et l'orge qui a
passé j'ai a passé 12 heures en quart
alors qu'en fait de strasbourg ap lma il
faut une heure et demie à deux heures de
vol dans la plupart des cas les gens
sont compréhensibles
donc les gens qui arrivent de france
comprennent le problème puisque la
presse française arrive
l'information arrive à passer en france
les gens qui sont à l'étranger bien sûr
ne lis pas les journaux français sont en
vacances en plein
militante et fantasy surpris de se
retrouver à gérone on ne trouvait sur
l'aéroport de nous par les plus
favorisés des touristes sont sans
conteste les allemands il ne survole que
très peu la france
les belges et les français nous voulons
le voir on recourt à lautoka en revanche
les plus touchés sont les anglais
ce matin déjà certains leur vol avait
sept heures de retard
demain cela devrait empirer le problème
en ce moment les retards pour à peu près
de 7 8 heures pour l'arrivée non des
attentes qui vont jusqu'à 7 heures
proposée par geronimo est ce que vous
voyez la fin du week-end catastrophique
tout le monde est là trophique en france
que si ça continue comme ça ça va être
plus de 24 heures de retard pour les
votes que c'est un minimum
j'avais déjà vu ça dans votre carrière
dans sa mère d'aller aux deux choses
aussi graves
à présent à gérer le système d a pris
une dimension internationale
on s'organise comme on peut pour
l'instant les grincements de dents se
font plutôt rares
mis à part peut-être certains de nos
compatriotes quant au flegme britannique
il trouve là un excellent terrain pour
s'exprimer pleinement de l'aéroport à
l'avion de l'avion aucun les bagages
finissent par peser lourd
c'est là que l'on s'aperçoit que l'on
appris beaucoup de choses inutiles
évidemment l'une des conditions
essentielles d'un retour sans trop de
difficulté c'est le beau temps alors de
rendre eux mêmes quels il le sera le
temps pour cette nuit pour la route et
demain matin et bien si vous avez
consulté la girouette qui est au sommet
de l'église de votre village vous avez
pu constater que le vent vient du nord
aussi bien les températures sont
relativement fraîches cette nuit moins
de 10 degrés par exemple au nord de la
loire ce qui sera peut-être plus gênant
pour les automobilistes ce sera la brume
regarder la photographie prise par le
satellite meteosat hier à 9 heures du
matin il y a quelques petits points
verts qui correspondent à des nuages bas
un peu partout sur l'aquitaine le
nord-est la vallée du rhône par exemple
on pourrait bien retrouver cette brume
demain matin par endroits elle se
transformerait même éventuellement en
brouillard avec une visibilité
inférieure à un kilomètre
la gêne sera t'il assez faible sauf sauf
exception dans les vallées les cuvettes
et près des plans d'eau attention donc
dans la journée vient du soleil à peu
près partout avec des températures tout
de même en légère baisse à coups
du vent du nord doublage quand même plus
abondants sur le nord-est et le nord
quelques pluies en perspective du pas de
calais aux vosges et puis l'après midi
des orages des nuages sur les pyrénées
et l'aquitaine attention donc lundi et
bien cette fois ça s'aggrave nettement
des nuages plus abondant à peu près
partout sauf sur les régions
méditerranéennes
et pour une fois sur la bretagne il ya
donc des nuages quelques averses au nord
vous auriez intérêt peut-être à prévoir
un paradis de votre voiture
et puis éviter de vous abriter sous les
arbres dans l'aquitaine au massif
central
ercis finalement il ne reste qu'une
perruque et une fausse moustache entre
les mains des policiers suisses pour
tenter de deviner quel est l'auteur du
détournement hier du boeing de la twr la
plupart des passagers ont été relâchés
après vérification d'identité et tout le
monde se demande si on découvrira un
jour celui qui a pris plaisir à jouer
avec l' angoisse de 80 passages chaque à
douchapt oui le fantôme du boing voyage
au bout de l'absurde ses titres de
journaux traduisent bien la perplexité
de leurs auteurs car 24 heures après le
faux détournements john elle demeure
aussi mystérieux une ombre une
silhouette remettant un message à
l'hôtesse de l'air et ce fut le grand
chambardement alerte état d' alerte
déclenchée à genève est un major de
crise convoquée à washington et puis dix
heures d'angoissé pour les passagers
10h02 tentatives de négociations avec
qui et bien tout simplement avec le
fantôme d'un pirate et au bout du compte
comme seule pièce à conviction une
perruque une fausse moustache et des
mines m c'est à la fois risible et
tragique qui a pu donc imaginé un tel
coup de bluff s'agit-il d'un terroriste
d'un fou dangereux ou encore d'un simple
farceur peu importe il aura réussi une
première dans l'histoire mouvementée de
la piraterie aérienne
le détournement d'un appareil hors de la
présence physique constatée réel de
l'auteur ainsi donc hier à genève on a
peut-être assister à la naissance d'un
nouveau personnage le pirate invisible
un fantôme de terroristes ou jouant avec
la vie de 80 otages sinistre canular qui
utilisent
comme pour rire larmes absolue du
chantage en bref il se confirme après le
conseil restreint de l'elysée hier que
le gouvernement s'est mis d'accord sur
un déficit minimum de 15 milliards de
francs pour le prochain budget de 79 à
l'étude un certain nombre de mesures
prévoyant en particulier la réduction de
certains avantages fiscaux octroyés à
quelques quatre catégories de
contribuables clôture à toulouse du
congrès nationale de la libre pensée a
noté l'inquiétude manifestée par le
secrétaire général de la fédération de
l'éducation nationale monsieur andré
henry au sujet de la prochaine rentrée
scolaire si les déclarations du nouveau
ministre de l'éducation reste louable
étrange heureusement avec celle de son
prédécesseur déclare monsieur henry il
ne reste pas moins que la situation est
grave et préoccupante pour cette
nouvelle rentrée et le secrétaire de la
fen à jour qu'une politique nouvelle de
l'éducation est nécessaire mais qu'elle
exigera des idées des moyens et beaucoup
de courage
après edmond maire pour la cfdt andré
bergeron l'eau force ouvrière c'est le
secrétaire général de la cftc jean
bernard qui définit ce soir
la préoccupation majeure de son syndicat
à la veille de la rentrée sociale si
jean bernard estime comme ses homologues
que le chômage dossier numéro un ils
divergent quelque peu sur le moyen d'y
remédier edmond maire et andré bergeron
vous en souvenez avait insisté sur la
diminution nécessaires à leurs yeux de
la durée du travail
le leader à seftc lui considère que
c'est par la relance économique que l'on
pourra parvenir à stopper l'augmentation
des demandeurs d'un peu à la cftc devant
cette rentrée on a vraiment beaucoup
d'inquiétude
tout le monde sait que la situation de
l'activité économique est très faible et
il faut absolument relancer l'emploi
les négociations traînent en longueur et
il faut là aussi débloquer les
conventions collectives à la certifiant
de très attaché aussi à faire avancer
deux dossiers à l'occasion de cette
rentrée celui des défavorisés car il ya
des oublis
et notamment en matière de politique
familiale où les retards sont
considérables et puis aussi le dossier
des réformes de structure de
l'entreprise notamment où il faut
vraiment manifesté concrètement qu'on
veut associer les salariés à la vie
économique
vous voyez qu'il faut faire pour cette
prochaine rentrée quelles sont vos
propositions pour lutter contre le
chômage y en a beaucoup mais je crois
qu'il faut d'abord prendre le problème à
la source
il ya un ralentissement est
incontestable la production industrielle
en ce moment est au même niveau qu'en
juin 10 974
c'est à dire que depuis quatre ans
monique mans il y à un tag nation
comment voulez vous qu'on résolve le
problème des créations d'emplois alors à
notre avis faut d'abord faire redémarrer
l'activité économique est bien sûr dans
les secteurs qui sont le plus
susceptibles de créer des emplois
nouveaux et d'autre part à notre avis il
faut aussi je crois nous réapprendre un
peu aux employeurs raconté dans la
sidérurgie les chantiers navals boussac
comme on vient de le voir les
entreprises ont tendance à réduire les
effectifs pour améliorer leur situation
mais ses effectifs il retombe sur le dos
de la collectivité et on améliore
certainement pas la situation générale
alors un autre avis il faut engager une
discussion dans les branches
professionnelles dans les entreprises
dans les régions pour avoir vraiment une
autre politique économique une autre
politique de l'emploi et trouver le
moyen par des conditions de travail
améliorées de vraiment créer des emplois
nouveaux
c'est absolument nécessaire vous avez
pris le journal en route
je vous rappelle que le successeur de
paul 6 vient d'être élu c'est le tri mad
patriarche
venise qui a pris le nom de jean paul
1er et voici les images de la première
bénédiction papale de jean paul 1er
l'outil rassemblé fulham
en grande majorité des roumains et
sudoku de d'étrangers de des vacanciers
qui ont préféré attendre et participer à
la conduite à du conclave
c'est la première apparition de nouveaux
phares en public
tous
dans quelques instants il va prononcer
la bénédiction en latin la bénédiction
urbi et orbi sa suivi par incendie
depuis ses cloches comme
je pense qu'il attend voilà vous vous
doutez il attend le micro ce tube en
option qui après soul hip et recettes
par des couloirs une protestante et
anthony taquet confirmé mousse ipsi que
retiennent prenant de sa dent
la silhouette meritus en totalité par
les temps sont en musée a trouvé le
poteau et démystificatrice vestri 112
tout cas devant ce qui est juste crise
tous invitent à mithra
une dose initiale absolution lui et
transforme en catastrophe parce une
verrée trottoirs et ntic
car ces internautes ont été mises à sion
une vie gracia mais consolation 910
spiritus et final une persévérance elles
nous fournissent aux primaires ce tri
boîtes vendues au mythe autour cesari
cause dans me1 que bénédicte sur die en
hypothèse pas été fait et tout spiritus
un petit déchirement c'est ma merde cmp
en effet seulement jean paul 1er très
ému aux antilles oui j'ai trouvé un peu
plus amaigris que sur les premières
photos le premier film que devant lui
tout à l'heure mais il a un excellent
sourire un très beau sourire stress
qu'on est une question peut être un peu
délicate mais ce qu'on a des
renseignements sur sa santé physique
c'est toujours un peu la même chose
lorsqu'on a affaire à un homme public et
de ses cibles pape est un homme public
louis la santé l'élément important quand
il a été nommé cardinal il ya cinq ans
on disait que c'était un homme en pleine
de puissance de tous ses moyens afin
qu'il était en pleine force et à venise
il est très aimée à venise alors ce sont
des indications manque préfère vous
savez le peuple quand il devient peuple
est différent de ce qu'il était
auparavant parce que la fonction d'une
certaine façon le transforme alors on ne
peut pas dire à l'avancé ce qu'il va
devenir
et on ne sait pas alors l'avenir dira
les cérémonies nous continuons le coût
de ce journal les cérémonies
d'anniversaire de la libération de paris
se sont terminées hier par des feux
d'artifice et par un son et lumière qui
a montré aux jeunes parisiens comment la
génération précédente s'était soulevée
pour libérer sa lune il y à 34 ans le
ton donc était à la fête et le maire de
paris n'a sans doute pas eu le temps de
confronter avec les maires des autres
grandes villes du monde qui l'avait
invité en particulier moscou et new york
ces idées et aussi ses problèmes dont la
pesanteur est telle qu'on se demande
finalement si la grande ville
megalopolis n'est pas condamnée si elles
n'échappent pas déjà à la volonté de ses
habitants
new york une longue lutte en un budget
de 64 milliards de francs récemment en
déficit
10 milliards le maire est élu pour
quatre ans au suffrage universel direct
moscou 8 millions d'habitants également
mais un budget de 17 milliards de francs
seulement président du soviet de moscou
le maire est nommé pour cinq ans par les
conseillers de circonscription paris
deux millions et demi d'habitants pour
un budget de 7 milliards et demi
le maire et élus pour six ans par les
conseillers municipaux new york moscou
paris froid capitale dont le gigantisme
finit par effrayer
pourtant aucun des trois maires n'estime
que le temps des médias paule soit
révolu le chacun donne une raison
différente
vous pouvez prendre les sept plus
grandes villes des états unis et les
transplanter dans la ville de new york
sur le plan population les sept sont
très belles mais aucune ne pourra être
comparée avec la vie passionnante le
modernisme et l'audace qui existe à new
york
nous avons tellement de personnes qui
vivent côte-à-côte 150 nationalités
religion ou ethnie différente et nous
vivons tous ensemble pour ainsi dire
sous le même toit
ce ne devrait pas voir cela change et
malgré les problèmes chez niveau de
chaque jour les moscovites ne considère
pas qu'il est difficile de vivre dans
une grande ville nous pensons que c'est
normal mais nous ne voulons plus
agrandir moscow il vaut mieux développer
les autres villes et y mettre les
industries d'ailleurs à moscou
nous ne construisons plus louzine au
contraire cela est même interdit
pourtant personne le crès le chômage
notre plus grand problème est même
aujourd'hui celui du manque de mandeure
c'est les grandes villes sont dans la
nature humaine de l'évolution
sociologique des pays eux comporte de
grands inconvénients elle exige des
efforts importants pour que le mode de
vie soit acceptable compte tenu des
exigences légitimes des populations
maison par ailleurs une capacité unique
est nécessaire de création
d'entraînement de puissance est une
grande nation doit avoir de grandes
cités alors que le problème c'est de
rendre la vie dans ces sites est
compatible avec je le répète les
exigences légitimes des habitants
c'est un grand problème mais comme tout
problème il a une solution à partir du
moment où on le veut mais si paris était
à recréer maintenant est-ce que vous
verriez paris de la même façon jean ne
crée pas une ville ex nihilo à partir
devient une ville c'est le résultat
d'une longue histoire
qu'il s'agisse de moscou qui se disent
aussi de new york il s'agit de pas et de
toutes les villes
c'est le résultat de toute une tradition
et c'est ça qui fait la force d'une
ville
ainsi d'ailleurs que sa capacité à
s'adapter et ça c'est le rôle des hommes
qui les dirigent aux exigences de leur
temps en bref encore je vous signale
avec regret la mort hier à paris du
comédien liés au snow il était âgé de 65
ans il avait été d'abord clerc de
notaire ce qui correspondait sûrement
moins son terme par aman que la comédie
qui choisit ensuite de jouer l'idiot
hussenot avait créé avec jean pierre
grenier cette fameuse compagnie grenier
hussenot que les comédiens considère
comme l'héritière spirituelle de jacques
copeau le pâtissier de florence 9e rang
jean moselle qui avait mortellement
blessé jeudi soir d'un coup de carabine
un garçon de 13 ans qui tentait de
pénétrer chez lui vient d'être inculpé
et mis en prison à metz en revanche le
juge d'instruction d'ajaccio accordé cet
après-midi la liberté provisoire sous
contrôle judiciaire au prince victor
emmanuel de savoie le prince vous savez
est inculpé de coups et blessures pour
avoir tiré sur un jeune allemand de 19
ans l'état de ce dernier s'améliore mais
il a dû être amputé d'une jambe
la décision du juge d'instruction des
réactions sera exécutoire si le parquet
ne fait pas appel enfin à lille un
mystère le gagnant du dernier gros lot
du loto ne s'est toujours pas manifestée
pour empocher son gain
il dispose d'ailleurs d'un délai
moi pour le faire jouer de vous dire
qu'il s'agit d'un gros lot de 650
millions de centimes
on souhaite que le gagnant reviennent de
vacances demain et sa peur soit ils ont
aperçoivent lundi il aura au moins en
france un homme qui pourra faire ses
comptes de rentrer sans souci sport
maintenant berlin-ouest il s'agit des
championnats du monde de natation
la soviétique irina kalinin a a remporté
tout à l'heure son deuxième titre
mondial de plongeon de haut vol
et ce malgré un vent violent qui a gêné
toutes les concurrentes en football
maintenant c'est le nantais bruno
baronchelli qui remplacera pour le match
de france suède le 1er septembre
prochain
le stéphanois dominique rocheteau blessé
vous savez hier soir au cours du match
paris saint germain
saint-etienne un match qui s'est terminé
vous savez par le score de 1 partout et
qui a été le théâtre de la rentrée comme
joueurs de jean michel larqué
mais il y avait un autre homme sur le
terrain que les 45000 spectateurs du
parc des princes ont beaucoup regardé il
s'appelle laurent paganelli
et c'est la première fois qu'il jouait
en équipe professionnelle de
saint-etienne il est âgé de 15 ans et
demi jamais on n'avait vu sur le terrain
ce niveau bien entendu un joueur
professionnel aussi jeune reporter je
pense que nous allons voir les ihm la
présence des verts au parc des princes
plus la rentrée de jean michel larqué
égale 48 mille spectateurs
le phénomène stéphanois est toujours
bien vivant notamment semble-t-il dans
le coeur des parisiens le psg à droite
sur votre écran défend une balle en
profondeur et lee y croient ils
empêchent de sortir
regardez sont proches côte à la
réception 1 à 0 un modèle du genre
la réaction parisienne est immédiate
un corner morin le tir bas tenaient là
une bien jolie fête c'est l'égalisation
impact 29 est à sa manière son nouveau
brassard de capitaine
mais la révélation la soirée c'est ce
petit diable vert de 15 ans et nuit il
s'appelle laurent paganelli et rentre en
seconde mi temps à la place de rocheteau
touché aux adducteurs
paganelli est à l'aise au parc il y a
déjà joué avec l'équipe de france
minimes en compagnie de son ami laurent
roussey qui lui est un vieux routier de
16 ans et demi c'est une première dans
les annales du football professionnel
français jamais jusqu alors un joueur
n'avait tenté cette expérience au 6 juin
au parc des princes de surcroît devant
un public difficile et sans complaisance
laurent paganelli a plu au parisien il a
réussi sa rentrée bien évidemment
certaines de ces initiatives ont manqué
de finition péché de jeunesse
ce journal a été quelque peu bouleversé
vous n'êtes le constater encore par l'
annonce très peu de temps à lever avant
l'ouverture de l'édition de l'élection
du nouveau pape jean paul 1er
le patriarche de venise berlin président
ou es ce que vous avez quelques
nouvelles
informations provenant de rome document
si on est encore au pu avoir une
nouvelle communication avec nos envoyés
spéciaux
je pense que nous allons avoir très
rapidement mais je voulais simplement
vous dire qu'il ya quelques réactions
déjà en france après l'élection de
nouveaux pas celle d'évêques français en
particulier monseigneur vincent l'évêque
de bayonne qui est surpris l'élection de
monseigneur luciani mais qui se réjouit
cette élection monseigneur sabin de 5 go
d'un évêque d'agen se réjouit lui aussi
de cette élection et monseigneur gufflet
qui évêque de limoges dit je suis très
heureux que de nouveaux pas que je ne
connais pas personnellement mais j'ai
entendu beaucoup de bien de j'ai entendu
dire beaucoup de bien de lui
une dernière précision il a souvent été
question durant ces journées de
conciliabules de contact entre les
cardinaux on disait qu'il fallait que le
pape est une qualité essentielle celle
de diplomates de connaissances aussi de
l'ensemble de l'église
croyez vous que le patriarche de venise
nouveau pontife et cette connaissance de
l'église et des hommes je crois qu'on
avait une image précédente avec de très
grands diplomates comme pie xii ou paul
6 mais il me semble que avec le concile
et l' influence du concile sur
l'ensemble des évêques et l'ensemble des
élèves qui sont devenus cardinaux parce
que beaucoup de cardinaux le sont depuis
assez peu de temps et de l'ensemble des
cardinaux ont été influencés par le
concile et désire avoir plus un pasteur
qu'un diplomate et je crois que là ils
ont voulu choisir un pasteur et que ceux
qui voulaient encore avoir un diplomate
se référer à des images précédentes mais
non pas aux besoins peut être
primordiaux de l'église aujourd'hui
merci vous nous vous préparons une
édition complète vers 23h10 que bernard
pradines au vous présentera avec
l'élection de ce nouveau pape
voici la première bénédiction
cette bénédiction d'ailleurs noté
patrice et affi et tout ce qui est tout
ça monte mais sheila sous-paiement cette
main verte celle où peur donc rendez
vous dans notre prochaine émission 23h10
en attendant la rédaction d'antenne de
mon fils vous souhaitez le bon cela
ah ah